we're going to get an unprecedented look
today at gm's new electric hummer it's
something the company calls a super
truck we have to acknowledge it is also
super expensive starting price is about
110 000
and yet online reservations to buy it
are higher than general motors initially
expected and to prove that the hummer ev
is a worthy investment the company has
decided to trust our chris van cleave
behind the wheel for the truck's first
test drive on network television
the hummer is back and leaving its 10
miles per gallon legacy in the dust
this 1 000 horsepower monster is all
electric it's just the next step you
know it's the future
ingo hagman already has an old military
humvee and was among the first to get
the 2022 gmc hummer ev i spend about 13
1400 a month in gas and it's just very
high it's a small mortgage payment
the gulf war made the humvee a household
name and 30 years ago arnold
schwarzenegger used his star power to
help turn it into an unapologetic suv
that could go just about anywhere
gm added the h2 and smaller h3 before
surging gas prices and the great
recession halted production
duncan allred runs gmc what message do
you think it sends when the iconic
american gas guzzler goes electric it
just opens pretty much everybody's eyes
including any potential ev non-believers
it's a huge turning point a huge signal
for the wider market at large that
signal
is an electric future the ford f-150 has
been the nation's best-selling vehicle
for decades its all-electric lightning
debuts this spring
last month cadillac began production of
its first electric suv the lyric and
upstart rivien's new midsize pickup won
motor trends 2022 truck of the year
dozens of other new evs will hit the
streets over the next few years we're
coming to the point soon where driving
an electric car is the only financially
sensible thing to do cnet's brian cooley
the total cost of ownership of an
electric car is close to eclipsing a
combustion engine car and consumers love
to vote with their wallets as gas prices
climb online searches for evs are
surging up 173 percent last month 55
percent of gas-powered car owners say
they're considering going electric
gmc already has 65 000 reservations for
the new hummer despite a price tag
topping six figures okay so we break
hard yep and now we floor it you could
say
it's going fast
like 0 to 60 in three seconds fast
wow you feel that
[Laughter]
we're on a closed course outside phoenix
and under the supervision of hummer
engineer kirsten hansen she believes
this is the ev to silence critics
electricity is the future and if they
can't see how cool a thousand horsepower
and three electric motors are then i
can't help them she also may not be able
to help my off-road driving terrain mode
i feel like is the chris shouldn't be in
mode
terrain mode is for everybody
careful
seventy percent of those ordering the
hummer ev are new to electrics including
ingo hagman you've gone green would you
think you'd ever go back honestly i
don't see a reason to go back
unapologetically plugging into a future
free of guzzling gas for cbs mornings
i'm chris van cleave in phoenix
the game has changed yes yes yes i like
it people used to look at
those that drove hummers differently and
it's not the same
that sideways move with the crap
yeah
you're going to get one
hey i don't think you can park that
thing